ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner
[Music]
one of the stagehands came over to me
backstage and he said show was running
pretty long tonight he says maybe it
should be called awards and remembrance
well he's only a stage name not a writer
you know the word and legend gets tossed
around rather loosely these days army
Archerd says hello dia out front two
years in a row for alleged but there are
two people would you bring that back a
little please you went too fast there
are two people okay I'll read it then
tonight it is my privilege to introduce
two people who not only personify comedy
greatness who not only are beloved by
millions of people in virtually every
corner of the globe who not only had
been delighting audiences for half of
this century but who are among the only
people I can think of who could get me
to come here from Pacoima
words with a C in it are funny to make
this introduction
ladies and gentlemen Lucille Ball and
Bob Hope
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how about that how about it thank you
ladies and gentlemen what a night I
haven't seen so many gorgeous girls
since I spent Father's Day with Steve
Garvey
but I've got the most gorgeous girl
right by my side Lucille Ball right
there it really is wonderful to be here
in a particular thriller especially
would will you Bob it's a very secure
feeling being up here with a man who has
been on the oscar show 26 times that's
true and never one
[Applause]
you have to mention of that Wow I may
take a Chilean grape no it's not that I
have not today what are you gonna do not
that I haven't begged that's I do that
I've been on my knees more often than
Billy Swaggart anyway a lot of people
are wondering what Lucy and I are doing
up here together you know we made four
pictures together yeah talk about
Dangerous Liaisons even though we
haven't worked in a while we're still
keep in touch with everything in fact
today the ayatollah khomeini called me
and asked me who wrote Ishtar and I hear
they offered you a role in the picture
about Dan Quayle's visit to the White
House
yeah the accidental tourist actually I
was called back to Washington the paper
train the puppy oh you know Milly the
White House dog had three puppies
actually she had five but the Senate
rejected two
uh-huh can we stop now no we're on a
roll why did he stop now I want to tell
you we may get a better offer Lucy's
right though we got a lot to say here
and we get a very important thing to say
because we know who the winners are yes
and we haven't even opened the envelopes
yeah you're about to see 19 of the
hottest young actors and actresses and
pictures these are the people who will
be winning Oscars way into the next
century that's right you've already seen
the max in hit movies but tonight you're
gonna see them sing and dance
you know Bob I've always felt that
hidden within every great actor is a
song-and-dance man yeah you're telling
me
in my in another life I was Shirley
MacLaine anyway here we are with 19
triple letters make a note of their name
now you're gonna be hearing a lot from
these kids ladies and gentlemen the
Oscar winners of tomorrow in a number
especially written for this year's show
by Marvin Hamlisch and Fred eV and
choreographed by Kenny Ortega
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
day
I'll be
who walks up here accepting the bra
[Music]
and dog grabbed him with tears in my
eyes
[Music]
don't tell me how to dress
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now watch the agents treating me right
[Music]
we'll be
[Music]
so I trained and I studied then I went
to those who teach movement and posture
and language and speech 2025 and I did
all my Jane Fonda cert sizes in case
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no I don't shoot and I don't dance I am
a thespian in the classic sense
don't talk to me about paying dues I
waited tables in Manhattan for 10 years
and some of the finest restaurants in
West Hollywood
I am studied extensively I study was
Stella I studied with Strasbourg I study
Stanislavski I am a serious actor I was
on dynasty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Jeff Goldblum and
Academy Award winner Geena Davis
[Applause]